nous gaspillons trop de médicaments
c'est en raccourci l'illustration du
problème du déficit de la sécurité
sociale malgré l'augmentation des
cotisations en début de cette année
rien n'est réglé d'une façon durable ce
mois ci la sécurité sociale annonce des
difficultés de trésorerie
voici les explications de jacques mirlin
au déficit de la sécurité sociale risque
de faillite de l'assurance chômage
menace sur les retraites
nous sommes habitués à ces cris des
larmes qui reviennent régulièrement
depuis quelques années c'est que le
problème est tout à fait réelle
l'ensemble de ceux dépenses sociales
atteint des sommets vertigineux elles
dépasseront cette année les 500
milliards de francs plus inquiétant
encore les augmentent plus vite que
notre développement économique
posant ainsi à terme un véritable
problème de société
la sécurité sociale constitue bien sûr
ce n'est pas cela par la plus importante
avec près de 300 milliards de francs la
caisse maladie dans déficit chronique
la caisse vieillesse temps difficiles
depuis trois ans la caisse allocations
familiales par contre est excédentaire
alors qu'elle est aujourd'hui exactement
le risque
les 11 milliards qui manquent à la
trésorerie malgré le relèvement récent
des cotisations sont la conséquence
d'une évolution modérée des salaires et
d'un chômage important mais ils peuvent
s'expliquer aussi par un décalage
provisoire entre les dépenses et les
recettes
quant au déficit de 1 milliard annoncée
pour la fin d'année cela appelle deux
remarques
la première est que les prévisions en
matière de sécurité sociale sont
extrêmement difficiles
la seconde est qu'un milliard représente
à peine plus que le montant des dépenses
d'une seule journée